[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
alrighty we'll get some more phone calls
coming up he's Nick Wright the popular
co-host on Fox Sports 1 first things
first and I had a great Sunday there
with the Kansas City Chiefs winning the
Super Bowl congratulations Nick
thank you Dan but this does put a lot of
pressure on me now into 2023. I got to
tell you how come
well as I'm sure you know I was you know
recently named the most accurate Sports
pundit of 2022 and now when 2023 starts
off with you know me nailing the
entirety of the playoffs it's just you
know you try to keep this run going uh
you know I know many people in the
industry fell in love with the Buffalo
Bills they had a brief flirtation with
the Miami Dolphins uh the Eagles were
the better team the Bengals were the
better team and little old Nick Wright
said you know
I'm gonna go out on a limb and say the
team that has clearly the best
quarterback we've ever seen and the best
coach currently coaching that team
shouldn't be an underdog in back-to-back
playoff games one at home and one on a
neutral site and because of that you
know and the fact that it's my hometown
team as well and you know I'm going to
be in the parade tomorrow it's just a
lot going on here Dan but I made time
for you my friend are you gonna be in
the parade
yeah of course oh would I not be no
don't be super I mean I'm I mean me and
Paul Rudd I would assume are the two
most famous Kansas cityians now that
Harry Truman is no longer with us I'm
not sure who else is in the discussion
uh Eric Stone Street
well of course well Eric I thought you
know I should have mentioned that
because Eric Stone treats a friend he is
also in the parade or at least involved
in the festivities I did not mean to not
mention Eric I was already I was just
talking to Eric the other day we're in a
Kansas City you know the Kansas City
Elite group chat is what we're in yeah
so not a lot of beaches there not a lot
of us yeah not a lot of people on that
call but that's okay
that's all we need yeah more do we need
yeah I don't need what's your hometown
Dan uh well I'm from Cincinnati
from Cincinnati yeah oh
most famous cincinnatians Jerry
Springer's got you sorry
um I pay cash not check
oh
by the way Happy Valentine's Day
oh thank you to you as well I even we
can talk about whatever you want but
just make sure we have two minutes at
some point in this for me to tell you a
great story about your long-lost great
producer McLovin okay well we can do it
now
you wanna do it now yeah sure okay let's
do it now okay so Friday night at the
Super Bowl I'm at the casino as I'm
often there uh with my wife who you know
her best friend in the world Nicole and
the guy who produces my uh radio or my
TV shows uh Hubbard and there's a big
party going on Shaq's fun house
and we were already planning to go to
the Drake's party later in the evening
but it was early and I was like why
don't we stop by Shack's thing and
they're like we don't have tickets I'm
like let's just see let's figure out see
what's what and as I'm walking up I see
McLovin
and he says hi and I'm like hey do you
need tickets to this thing he's like
yeah I think you do but I have red
carpet entry and I didn't say this out
loud but I'm like
you have red carpet injury then I think
I'm gonna be okay and so I'm like where
is it and he's like it's around back
here he's like you want to just follow
me I'm like yeah I'm just gonna follow
you buddy and he walks over he's with
somebody he's like can I yeah everybody
knows his real name he's like perloff
too they're like okay they give him
wristbands and I just walk up right
after and I'm like Nick Wright before
and they're like you're not on the list
and I'm like and I just kind of gestured
I'm like yeah but i r and I and they
were like and somebody was like okay go
ahead and so and so I'm waiting then to
walk the red carpet
and perloff
has was wearing like a jacket and it
when I saw him but he has now taken the
jacket off and is doing like bodybuilder
poses on the red carpet
and I'm like this is a hell of an act
I've gotta follow and then yeah we're on
there yeah it's a true story you needed
McLovin to get you into Shaq's party
well I needed once I heard McLovin was
had red carpet injury I was like you
know what I think I'm gonna be able to
swing this one I think I'm gonna show up
and and it's gonna be okay and so yeah I
did that true story did you go to the
game
no I did not I can't watch that football
game around Eagles fans are you kidding
me I watched that in my house chain
smoking cigarettes by myself nervous
wreck and then when the game's over I
say there was never a doubt but I was
scared man well I would have been
terrible I do I think you did say that
they're going to blow him out can you
don't you quoted I predicted 34-20 Dan
and you know what even the most accurate
Sports pundit of 2022 according to
Reuters you know has some misses and I
did not think Jalen hurts had that game
in him you know he comes out of that
game looking as good as any Super Bowl
losing quarterback I can remember the
fact that he had an unforced error that
directly led to seven points and nobody
is like using that against him
everyone's like nope he was awesome
shows you how great he was but where I
was correct in my analysis was that this
Eagles defense was not an all-time great
defense it was not the I don't care what
the sack numbers were is not the 85
Bears they played in the regular season
four quality starting quarterbacks three
of those four scored 33 Plus on them and
I just knew the analogy I used and I
don't know if you ever did this when you
know you've lived in the Northeast for a
while uh when it like turns to Winter I
wait as long as I possibly can before I
wear a heavy coat that way when it gets
really cold I've kind of built up some
tolerance like okay now the code will
make me feel good I I don't feel like
the eagles had built up any tolerance to
good quarterbacking they just played
Daniel Jones Davis Webb and Brock Purdy
with one arm and so when Patrick Mahomes
comes out there they have no answers to
that test and so I did I thought the
Chiefs would be able to score I wasn't
and the one other thing I'll say about
the game is because the Chiefs lost a
Super Bowl because they couldn't block
the other team's front I thought it was
very unlikely that with two years to
prepare if that were to happen again
that Mahomes be enemy and Reed would
lose another Super Bowl for the same
reason now they almost lost the Super
Bowl because Jalen hurts was just
awesome I mean he was just awesome and I
gave him a ton of credit but yeah so the
Eagles offense did better than I thought
they would yeah the defense was terrible
with the Eagles and got confused on you
know two easy touchdown passes uh with
Mahomes which to me was mind-baffling
you know it's like mind-boggling that
slay got lost there and all of a sudden
these guys are wide open and it's not
Kelsey who's wide open so that that to
me was kind of alarming there they don't
get to Mahomes at all and I go back to
the play with Hertz
it should have been 27 7 at halftime it
like it felt like the eagles had
dominated that much and the fact that
they went into halftime only up 10 and I
say only up 10 because that's nothing
from homes that's where I thought you
know what the chief Chiefs can win this
one so the chiefs were plus 4 10. on the
live line at halftime and that to me was
Insanity especially because they were
getting the ball to start the second
half now maybe part of that was people
thought Mahomes was really injured and
like if Mahomes doesn't come back out
but the Mahomes double-digit comebacks
now Dan the the numbers here are jarring
so Mahomes in his career regular season
and postseason in games when he's down
10 or more at some point win wins
58 of the time yeah no Tom Brady's
second best at 39 Mahomes career playoff
double-digit comebacks he now has four
the only person who has more is Brady
with six moms has played in 14 playoff
games Brady 30 or 30 or uh what is it 48
and then lastly
in all of NFL history there have been
four double-digit second half Super Bowl
comebacks two by Brady two by Mahomes
that's the list so I I actually think he
gets more dangerous when he's trailing I
also I thought siriani coached a hell of
a game and I thought he was smart that
he stayed true to himself on the fourth
down stuff but there are two knits that
I would pick if I were an Eagles fan one
is the end of the first half when they
did get the ball back up seven
they seem to kind of slow roll that
whole drive just happy to get a field
goal as opposed to try to go for a
touchdown and then in the fourth quarter
when they were down one they had a
fourth and two now it was on their own
33-yard line I get that that's scary but
the chief said run had had such success
on that defense I feel like the mindset
there has to be field position does not
matter keeping the ball is what matters
they punted on that fourth and two and
that's when Tony hit the big punt return
and they got it he's uh Nick Wright
first things first co-host you can see
him every afternoon on Fox Sports One if
you're the Eagles do you sign up hurts
yeah uh to me that that game right there
I had major questions I no longer do I
thought
the people
my co-hosts on the show mocked me
because a lot of my analysis of young
quarterbacks is I go to how what they
did before they got to the NFL what was
their recruiting profile out of high
school what did they do in college and
one of my questions for Hertz was
if he faces adversity in the Super Bowl
do the ghosts of Collegiate playoff
benchings pass come back and haunt it
and the fact that he did have that
fumble six and then responded with his
arm and his legs
get his he's the best quote in the
league he's like and I that actually
matters in this regard like he seems
truly leadership motivational
inspirational a plus he is incredibly
tough
and he is to me shown more growth as a
passer in the last year
than and I hate to I'm not trying to
just Compare black quarterback to black
quarterback but Lamar who is a dynamic
Runner immediately to me Jalen has grown
more as a pastor in one year than I've
seen from Lamar and five and so yeah I'd
sign him up I'd absolutely sign him up
particularly in that conference where
the other best quarterbacks in football
all of them are in the other conference
yeah and that's why you look at the NFC
and and it sounds strange to say it the
Eagles might have a better chance of
getting back to the Super Bowl because
they don't have to worry about anybody
in the NFC other than San Francisco
whereas the Chiefs in the AFC
I mean have to worry about no one stop
it you're going to give more bullets and
board material Dan they're going to yell
at you at the parade more people that
doubted them they got to worry about
nobody they want 75 games in five years
they host the the AFC Championship game
is officially being renamed the
arrowhead Invitational they've never
lost in the AFC playoffs in regulation
their worst season since moms has taken
over is 12 wins a pro bowl and an
overtime AFC Championship Game loss they
have no easily be Owen three in the
Super Bowl they can easily be on three
in the Super Bowl stop that because the
the guy that that Mahomes is chasing
that could easily have three Super Bowl
wins and could easily have ten or nine
yes I I will make that decide that's a
discussion it's not a Counterpoint but I
think this could be 0-3 and Brady could
have lost three of those Super Bowls
that he won or he holds on to two more
or three and Mahomes also could be five
years in have having gone to five Super
Bowls he his first year he lost in
overtime when they didn't get the ball
and unlike those criminals
that happens I know give me a break
we're doing we're discussing who's more
annoying you or Jackson Mahomes
okay well first of all please don't talk
about you know royalty's brother like
that I I don't think that's fair
he's a civilian it's just because he has
a bigger Tick Tock following than you I
hint a little jealousy no I don't know
I'm gonna start dancing I'm gonna start
okay I would love I'd love to see that
you and McLovin at Shaq's party next
year a little dance off
um I'm not annoying I'm just always
correct on this wait what I just watch
Seton what well I've just noticed this
like Trend happening with Chiefs fans
the last 48 hours or something that
they're all very angry and very
defensive after winning the Super Bowl
where it's like dog what can't you guys
what about something nice for us why is
it only about the officiating why is
that the topic today why can't you say
good things about us it's like I mean
you guys just won chill out okay okay
well let's talk about the officiating
for a moment because I do think
you know as much as this pains me to say
that their you know the officiating will
Loom large over this game because you
saw a clear catch fumble touchdown taken
off the board for the Chiefs oh nobody's
talking about that oh it's all rigged
for the Chiefs except for you know the
touchdown they called a touchdown and
then took away oh what's the call
everyone's complaining about let me
check let me check my notes here oh the
one that in real time the referee and
the quarterback saw and post game the
good who had the flag thrown on him what
did he say he was like yes I absolutely
why are you so angry well I you know I'm
not afraid I'm celebrating you know what
they didn't they they overturned the
Devonte Smith catch which was wrong
there was a helmet to helmet against
Devonte Smith in the first quarter
nobody called that like if you want to
get you know into the minutia here and
yes they could have easily given the
Chiefs a touchdown on that that return
absolutely they did and then they took
it away yeah I have no problem I have no
problem with that you're sounding like
you're an Eagles fan here no I'm not an
eagles just celebrate you get me a
little riled up you didn't bring me on
here to celebrate you want me to wait if
I was letting you take a Victory lap you
don't sound like you can make it all the
way around the track like you're yelling
at everybody in the states a lot of
cigarettes this weekend so I don't know
if I can
but congratulations well thank you one I
mean Nate Robinson actually said the
exact score I know you're the you're the
most accurate pundit Nate Burleson said
Chiefs 38-35 but you know you want to
take a Victory lap go ahead you're wrong
with that just letting you know what did
what did Hoda Cobbs say the score she
had it bringing in television news
people now I'm sorry didn't Nate bro how
many games have you played in the NFL oh
you're playing that
cardson Nate Burleson on behalf of Nate
Burleson okay he made the call your
questioning is integrity because he
works in news I'm not questioning it you
just did and you questioned Hoda I dare
you a question not on my watch I asked
you you know don't do Savannah Guthrie
because then it's go time okay I was
gonna yeah because I was gonna ask you
who Gail King had in the game I'm not
certain I just don't know what we're
doing here that was a great job by Nate
38 35 that's a great job by Nate yeah
and by the way I don't know if Nate's a
gambler but I looked he could have
gotten 260 to one on that exact score
prediction I hope he put a few shekels
on it it's a great job I need I like him
one of the best looking people in sports
television yes he is her story yes he is
that's it that's all I got I just we're
done I wanted you to just take a Victory
lap and you you got defensive and then
you know I just you know you know you
know what when you're great you don't
have to get defensive
see you do it's all this little you
don't have to get defensive just ask me
when you're great you don't have to get
defensive I'm not defensive Dan how's
your wife is it a good day today
Valentine's Day you know she is in she
is still in Phoenix and she is now in
route to Kansas City to meet me okay for
the parade awesome going yeah I
appreciate that I'll send her your
regards yes uh yes I you know that that
you know it is odd now that you say this
you know maybe and I hate to do this
but maybe I do need to do some
introspection because I do get a lot
angrier when you question the greatness
of the Chiefs then when you openly hit
on my wife for the sixth straight show
maybe I do have some some unresolved
issues there maybe it's the ghosts of
Lynn Elliott and the no punt game and
blowing a 28 point lead to Andrew Luck
and having Marcus Mariota throw a
touchdown pass to himself to beat us in
the playoffs that has made me you know
very defensive of this dynastic run we
now have Who Do You Love More my homes
or your wife okay that's um you didn't
answer
they're different types of Love okay you
still didn't answer but that's I get it
it's different types of Love okay
well safe travels to Kansas City I will
thank you and once again congratulations
and I look forward to having dinner with
you again okay absolutely schedule
schedule now free so you and I I would
love to I would love to you and me
just us okay just us pal okay fair
enough thank you Nick
goodbye Dan that's Nick Wright
we're so good at ruining his day that's
nickra
then you openly hit on my wife for the
sixth show in a row
[Laughter]
I love that dude man I really do how can
he have a bad day
his Chief's just won